bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo de
smr vous savez on est le 9 décembre
vous savez ce que ça veut dire pour vous
c'est pas grand chose mais pour moi ça
veut dire beaucoup parce que le 9
décembre
je serais arrivé au mexique en vacances
n'est ce qui n'empêchera pas d'être
présent dans les commentaires comment
cette vidéo est là sortira j'avais envie
avant de vous parler du petit livre de
aux produits du jour truc que je kiffe
que je voulais vous présenter avant
d'ouvrir ce calendrier de l'avent des
cas de noël vous parler du contexte en
mémoire qui est le piste de réflexion un
petit peu comme l'autre jour je vous ai
parlé du corps humain pour le palu
mental j'ai une piste qui meurent est
peut-être pas d'en faire une vidéo
entière
quand on fait tout le reste de l'année
mais qui je crois sera intéressant sur
le fait de toujours chercher à
contextualiser sa mémoire
pareil il ya quelques jours à savoir le
4 décembre je vous ai parlé de comment
apprendre le morse et on a commencé à
parler vite fait de synesthésie par
rapport au son et à ce qu'au delà si
vous faites travailler le contexte
lorsque vous voulez apprendre une
information vous allez faire travailler
plusieurs choses à savoir aussi
peut-être le dorat à savoir louis
peut-être le goût c'est tout à fait
possible et des émotions
particulièrement qui ne rendent pas de
la synesthésie mais qui sont
intéressantes
pourquoi parce que en fixant toute cette
information vous allez encore créer des
associations comme vous êtes dit l'autre
jour qui vont renforcer l'assemblage de
souvenirs préexistants en vous parce que
ça reste que ça la mémoire c'est encore
une fois c'est assez rare qu'on y
rancune nouvelles données brutes
et là vous dites n'est pas bien comment
je fais pour travailler le contexte est
bien merci de leur imposer la langue
vous devez vous concentrer quand vous
cherchez à vous rappeler quelque chose
ou à réviser deux camps ou comment dans
quel état d'esprit était le moment de
l'apprentissage est ce que vous étiez en
train d'apprendre en cours chez vous
votre bureau etc etc en temps normal ça
va être assez simple de se souvenir mais
ça va pas vous provoquer quelque chose
de particulier parce que trop quotidien
et vous apprenez toujours régulièrement
dans le même contexte
maintenant imaginez que vous avez un
cours à apprendre particulier et c'est
très important d'apprendre secours au
lieu de l'apprendre chez vous dans votre
chambre se replier vous décidez d'aller
apprendre ce cours là dans un parc près
de chez vous pour aller à ce parc
vous mettez musique particulière la
musique que vous écoutez en ce moment et
vous aller à pied jusqu'à ce parc en
essayant déjà sur le trajet de vous
rappeler de ce qui vous est restée
spontanément de secours que vous avez
appris à l'école juste pour faire un
petit état des lieux vous avez la charge
de vous poser dans l'herbe au sol pour
garder un petit peu ce qui se passe
autour de vous vous pouvez laisser la
musique ou non suivant comment vous
fonctionnez pour vous travaillez moi je
sais que jacques ont plutôt que de la
musique vous respirez un petit peu les
eaux gardia vous prenez un chewing gum
particulier un bout que vous preniez pas
d'habitude par exemple symbian à
l'abricot et là vous travaillez sur
votre coin avec vos techniques de
mémorisation habituel du court lorsque
vous allez devoir vous rappeler plus
tard de secours pour le restituer que ce
soit lors d'une interrogé lors d'une
discussion ou pour votre culture
générale
vous allez voir que assez spontanément
ce contexte particulier d'apprentissage
va vous revenir peut-être le bout du
chewing gum peut-être le trajet
peut-être le parc en lui-même l'odeur du
parc les sens qui revient le parc l'état
d'esprit détendu que vous aviez quand
vous êtes assis au niveau émotionnel
mais tout ça va renforcer en fait va
fixer d'une manière différente votre
mémoire
donc voilà je pense qu'il ya une bonne
piste à travailler du côté du contexte
je crois que je le faire moi aussi un
peu plus régulièrement et à terme je
vous en ferai une vidéo sur tous les
avantages inconvénients que que j'en ai
ressorti mais je voulais partager ce
contexte avec vous avant d'acheter cette
vidéo comme d'habitude nous sommes dans
un calendrier de l'avent donc j'ai
préparé un petit quelque chose pour vous
qui est ici autour de moi dans les
particules et si je regarde ici ça veut
dire qu'il est en train d'apparaître
ici et là il s'agit d'une banque pour
les nuls qui peut monter d'ailleurs ou
descendre et les mauvaises langues
diront que c'est en post prod alors
qu'il est vraiment ici le big bang pour
les nuls expliquer simplement c'est une
version mise à jour
alors ceux qui connaissent un peu de la
scène etc stars savent que je suis
passionné vraiment en valeur par le big
bang et tu vas te dire dans les glaces
étaient passionnés pourquoi tu lis de
nouvelles choses parce que on n'en sait
rien encore
on croit qu'on sait mais c'est bien
souvent des hypothèses et certaines se
révèlent être fausse de trouverez en
avance comme ça ça c'est une version qui
est mise à jour puisque j'aime bien dans
la collection pour les nuls c'est que
voilà il ya toujours une chartre une
manière de traiter les choses un certain
humour et je trouve que cette version
l'a fait par la physicienne blandine
plus hachée et très complète et en même
temps très concise et assez drôle à lire
avec des anecdotes que je ne connaissais
pas donc si vous aimez ce délire là je
vous recommande ce livre dont je mets le
lien dans la description juste en
dessous de mon lien pour les places à
l'olympia où le qui s'appelle
singularité ce spectacle à l'olympia et
singularité sans référence au big bang
justement et ça vous le comprendrez lors
du final du spectacle
j'espère tu viendras tu peux mettre un
pouce en l'air si tu as aimé la vidéo
est abonné s'est pas encore fait le
calendrier de l'avent cette vidéo par
jour à 6 heures du matin deux légendes
jusqu'au 24 décembre à demain donc
[Musique]